here are three absolutely crazy facts
that you definitely didn't know about
One Piece starting with the fact that
samji was originally supposed to be
named after the main character of one
piece's biggest Rife hard to believe but
the straw hat Chef was originally going
to be named Naruto Naruto Maki is a
Ramen topping that looks like this very
fitting for a cook with spiral eyebrows
however once Arthur eats Oda learned of
another little-known anime called Naruto
he went for samji but this is nothing
compared to the time that the famous
Italian fashion brand Armani designed
these outfits for all the straw hat to
promote the one-piece film strong worlds
and I have to admit there is some real
drip going on right here not dropping as
hard as my jaw though when I found out
about fact number one you see Oda had
all the major story points already
planned out right from the beginning but
he just kept adding on more and more
details 25 years later and the story has
over 1 000 episodes and this fantastic
YouTube channel that you should
absolutely subscribe to but believe it
or not originally one piece was only
supposed to last for 5 years